et si on avait rangé n'augmente tour
trop tôt les températures négatives font
donc leur retour cette nuit et jusqu'en
milieu de semaine prochaine pour les
viticulteurs pas question de revivre
l'épisode dévastateur de 2021 où
certains avaient enregistré jusqu'à 80 %
de pertes depuis ils ont encore
renforcer leur arsenal de lutte contre
le gel le reportage amont tout sur cher
d'hélène chapelet
pour pouvoir dormir sur ses deux
oreilles les nuits où les températures
descendent sous la barre du zéro ce
vigneron loir et chérien vient
d'investir dans cette tour antigel
l'apal située au bout d'un mât de 12
mètres de haut fonctionnent au gaz et
protège à elle seule 4 à 5 hectares de
cultures la citerne qui l'alimentent est
pleine si le mercure chute les nuits
prochaines la tour se mettra donc en
marche automatiquement
il fait 10 degrés et là cela température
sélectionnés pour le démarrage 1,6 degré
on est sur un investissement à 45000
euros dès la première gelée elle est
déjà presque amortir la tour si on
considère 5 hectares de récoltes perdues
à 100% donc voilà et puis
sur une durée de vie de 15 ans je pense
que voilà il n'y a pas de y'a pas photo
quoi il faut dire que depuis son
installation en 2009 olivier
régulièrement été touchés par le gel ce
fut le cas en 2012 2016 2017 et 2021 lui
faisant perdre plus de 60% de sa récolte
le problème ce n'est pas tant le froid
mais les périodes de douceur qui font
sortir les bourgeons alors que le risque
de gelées n'est pas encore écartée on a
souvent des périodes où les températures
remontent au mois de mars où on va être
pendant une semaine deux semaines avec
des températures très positive où il
fait très beau c'est agréable on est à
20 degrés 25 degrés sauf que la living
ça va leur donner des signaux très forts
pour qu'elle se développe beaucoup plus
rapidement et donc du coup elles vont
sortir en végétation plus vite
historiquement c'est c'était peut-être
moins marquée en faite ou en tout cas
pas aussi régulier qu'on ait une période
d'au moins 2 mars qu'ils soient toujours
si chaud face à ces changements
climatiques olivier n'est pas le seul à
s'être équipé sur les villages montaut
sur cher et thésée une trentaine de
tours antigel ont été financés par des
vignerons regroupés en cuma